We discussed patient portals as a way to automate giving patients
their data that may be limited to data from a single health system.
We then looked at how a PHR or a fire app can make
this task more manageable across providers.
Could it be even easier for a patient to see
all their data no matter where they receive care?
Since they pay for most of it,
each provider's health insurance company,
should have a comprehensive view of their care.
No matter where it takes place.
This claims data has limitations.
For example, while claims would show when a lab test was performed,
they would not have the result.
However, it may often be
the most comprehensive longitudinal view of
a patient's care that is practically available.
Medicare's recognize that and his blue button on
fire initiative is an innovative approach to patient empowerment.
Paul LeBrone, my colleague and entrepreneur and residence at the CDC,
will now talk with Mark Scrimshaw,
Entrepreneur and residence at CMS to learn more about blue button on fire.